[Music]
last few weeks have brought growing
evidence of continuing attempts to
interfere with the upcoming 2018 midterm
elections on Thursday the White House
tried to show its taking the threat
seriously the administration brought out
top intelligence and law enforcement
official to detail what each department
is doing to try to combat foreign
influence here to talk in depth about
that and about those ongoing efforts to
disrupt is Derrick Thompson senior
editor at the Atlantic they're welcome
thank you
Facebook removed 32 pages and accounts
on Tuesday for what they called
coordinated inauthentic behavior which
is a new phrase in our vocabulary what
it what are they actually talking about
there well it's really interesting
because in a way this is like a spy
versus spy story yeah you know for
months supposed to remember Matt Maggie
yet no but for once for years people
have talked about Facebook as being a
surveillance machine misusing people's
private data right and then you have the
Kremlin which is the global espionage
leader of the last 50 years throughout
the world and so what you essentially
have here is like a john lecarre a novel
happening on social media you have the
Kremlin using disguised identities in
order to build and influence campaign
for the midterms and then you have
Facebook which is the sort of
surveilling master of social media using
its own artificial intelligence in order
to understand which of these accounts
are authentic and which of them are
coordinated in authentic attempts to
sway public opinion we should say they
did not attribute these accounts to the
Russians but intelligence officials
believe they probably are I think that's
exactly right that's it's important to
say that Facebook was careful in saying
we discovered this misinformation
campaign we noted a lot of similarities
to the Internet research agency which is
a Kremlin attached troll farm in Russia
and we believe that this is Russian we
can't necessarily prove it and why can't
they prove it because the Russians are
getting a lot more sophisticated about
these misinformation tactics they're not
buying in rubles they're going they're
buying in dollars they're using
third-party buyers they're using what
are called VPNs or virtual private
networks in order to disguise the origin
of these accounts these pages and this
advert
and buying so the Russians are getting a
lot more sophisticated the internet
research agency is getting a lot more
sophisticated but so is Facebook so how
did they find it if it's getting so much
more difficult to find someone like this
yeah they looked at a lot of sort of
content similarities a lot of these
pages are written in broken English and
they also looked at the fact that these
pages aren't necessarily being bought by
actual individuals there's clearly an
attempt to disguise the origin of these
purchases so they use a combination of
common sense and artificial intelligence
in order to root out these identities
and then they've shut down the pages 32
pages followed by 260,000 people I think
it's important to point out that when
you look at the content of these pages
it doesn't seem all that in the farías
or outside of the norm of Facebook at
the very least there's some
misinformation there is some so-called
fake news but it seems like some people
talk about immigration some people
talking about abolishing ice this is the
conversation that's already happening on
Facebook right well the thinking is that
these these pages were using relatively
normal content in order to build
audiences so that they could use
misinformation campaigns in the midterms
in November so we caught them while they
were imitating ordinary conversation and
we're building an audience but in fact
right they exact they were doing
essentially what pundits and influencers
do on this platform they were trying to
build an audience so that when the time
came in November they could strike so
how do we protect how does our
government how do tech companies protect
the midterm elections this is a really
really difficult question because what
you have here is a situation where you
know you go back to 2016 and both Donald
Trump and Mark Zuckerberg initially
resisted the idea that Russians were
using their organizations for propaganda
campaign Zuckerberg has come around and
said look I understand the Russians are
trying to misuse my platform I'm gonna
do something about it but that story
juxtaposes so violently to a story of
donald trump the lack of evolution of
the president of united states who
continues to offer apologies for russia
and refuses to very applicative his
intelligence advisors to say we're doing
our best to shut this down thank you so
much thank you